so what comes in your mind when somebody
says R Gean so if you're like me then
you might think a gene is a part of the
DNA which gets transcribed and forms
mRNAs and that we call gene expression
and that is how gene is expressed but
you know this concept is actually
incorrect
we cannot visualize genes like only a
part of the DNA because inside of a cell
two things matter first of all the phase
of the cell cycle we are talking about
because every phase of the cell cycle
gene expression does not happen so cell
cycle is just like our life cycle so
every phase of our life cycle we are no
not so active cell is also not so
transcriptionally active at every phase
of the cell cycle so we have to
understand which cell cycle phase we are
talking about and also at that point of
time what is the status of the chromatin
what is the compaction status of the
chromatin so gene is a part of chromatin
the bigger picture is the chromatin so
we cannot imagine gene a part of DNA
only we have to imagine gene as a part
of chromatin so the better picture is
something like this so we can understand
the cells then the cells the nucleus is
transcriptionally active in interface
where the chromatin landscape is
relatively relaxed and the dead cells
are transcriptionally active whereas
when the cells need to segregate its
chromosome they are in a rush hour and
they need to pack their DNA properly at
that stage the typical metaphysic
chromosome that we have in our mind is
highly condensed it is transcriptionally
inactive no transcription happens from
our compacted manifest metaphase
chromosome so which phase of the cell
cycle we are talking about thinking
about is very important
second of all if we talk about a gene
let's say a length of 1 KB we cannot
imagine a blunt picture of only DNA and
a segment of the DNA spanning one KB
because along with DNA there is histone
which is forming the nucleosome bead on
a string arrangement so if the gene
length is 1 KB and 1 nucleosome length
is roughly 200 base pairs so at least
there would be 5 histones 5 nucleosomes
along with the DNA so that is how we can
visualize a gene in our mind so the DNA
is compacted in a several levels first
level is like only DNA that that is how
a micrograph of teen it look like it's
like 0.12 one nanometer structure
whereas the nucleosome is a level 2
compaction which is a 1 to 10 nanometer
fiber but as a higher order compaction
is a chromatin fiber with increase of
complexity and compaction the chromosome
it's losing its ability to transcribe or
give rise to functional mRNAs now along
with histones the DNA's make a compact
chroma chromosome which kind of looked
like this and this is literally inactive
for transcription so let us look at how
these histone octamer forms so the
histone h3 and h4 forms h3 h4 dimer
whereas h2n2 reforms h2 A to B dimer and
that forms h3 for tetra Mar and H and H
3 t4 tetramer interact with h2 A to B
dimer to form a coral histone octamer
and that core histone octamer is wrapped
around by the T and in our DNA backbone
is negatively charged histone has
multiple positive residues mostly life
in an arginine so there is an ionic
interaction apart from ionic interaction
there are hydrogen bonding between them
so that is how DNA is wrapped around
these histone
in a chromatin fiber so now you can
understand why this kind of picture
shown here could be incorrect to
understand so we cannot so the UK in
eukaryotes the transcription or the gene
expression is pretty complicated because
first of all the RNA polymerase and its
associated general transcription factors
of transcription factor 2 family is a
huge complex and that complex need to be
recruited in the promoter and now RNA
polymerase has to scan through the whole
span of that nucleosome provided there
is a huge amount of obstacle in its path
so we can imagine that in a compact
situation it's literally impossible for
the trunk the RNA polymerase to run
along the length of a gene so somehow it
need to be loosened up a bit such that
RNA pol can move and can be released
from the promoter and can move along the
gene body and transcribing the mRNA so
the transition between a closed
chromatin to open chromatin is important
but how does this switch happens it
turns out there are specific histone
modifiers and nucleosome remodelling
complexes which can bring about this
change in histone modifiers can modify
the histone and can alter the degree of
interaction between the DNA and histone
and thereby can modulate the compaction
of the nucleosomes but as nucleosome
remodeling complex can slide the
nucleosomes away or increase the gap
between the nucleosome and thereby
reorganizing the flow chromatin
landscape in an atp-dependent manner so
together these kind of modifiers and
remodeling complexes can alter the
chromatin landscape and thereby aiding
in gene expression processes and also
nucleosome remodeling complex can either
change the spacing between the new
nucleosomes or it can slide it and also
it can replace with a histone with a pre
specific histone variant and it has been
seen with the active chromatin there are
signature histones which are associated
with an active
transcriptionally active chromatin so
that is how we should think about a gene
in a holistic chromatin landscape manner
not a isolated part of DNA and also
there are other sister Tori DNA elements
which aids in the degree of
transcription and how transcription
would be happening from the promoter and
those are enhancer sequence where
specific transcription factor binds and
in coordination with coactivator or
co-repressor it regulate how the
transcription would happen from the
promoter region so if you like my videos
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe to my
channel thank you